fireworks lit up the konya sky as
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
inaugurated the islamic solidarity games
four thousand athletes from 56 muslim
majority countries are taking part in
the tournament
for 25 year old saudi weightlifter
anushahiri these games are very
important
unity
unity and getting to know each other
more and make a community of this sport
and other sports
it's anu's first international
competition
but there are more experienced athletes
as well
ahmed behalu's grandparents were forced
to leave their home in haifa israel
during the six day war of 1967.
they settled in the oscar refugee camp
in nablus in the occupied west bank
his parents were born and raised there
as was ahamad himself
a lifelong dream was realized when the
palestinian taekwondo federation started
ahmed fighting in 2018. since then the
20 year old has participated in seven
international competitions and won six
medals including one gold
the difficulties we face are tremendous
international travel is one of the main
problems as getting a permit from israel
authorities is not easy we have limited
resources and poor facilities to train
and prepare for the games but despite
these obstacles we have achieved great
success and in these games in kanye i
will do my best to win a gold medal
ahmed has also set his size on
representing palestine at the 2024
olympics in paris
[Applause]
the islamic solidarity games isn't a
high-profile competition but for many
young athletes it's an opportunity to
showcase their talents
millions of muslims have been suffering
from poverty political instability and
even civil wars for decades despite the
availability of tremendous human and
natural resources some say this is
because of a lack of unity solidarity
and coordination and the organizers of
this game say their aim is to build
bridges among the muslim majority
countries by bringing them together
through supports the suicide al jazeera
konya